lights
section 19 of the Human Rights Act
confers a duty on the government to
ensure the provisions of this bill are
compatible with that convention ensuring
this compatibility is not only a basic
moral requirement for government it's
also a practical necessity because this
government has said this is critical
legislation and therefore they are
presenting Clauses to this house which
they know will probably be ruled
unlawful by a court of law so surely Mr
Speaker if the government wants to have
a fight with the courts it should have a
fight with the courts and not waste this
house is time with this piece of
Nefarious legislation I am grateful for
the point of order that's not something
that the chair can adjudicate but I'm
sure that it will be part of the debate
which I think we should start now Home
Secretary
Mr Deputy speaker I beg to move that the
illegal migration Bill be now read a
second time
the British public know
that border security
is National Security that illegal
migration makes us all less safe
they know that the financial and social
costs of uncontrolled and illegal
migration are unsustainable they know
that if our borders are to mean anything
we must control who comes into this
country and the terms under which they
remain here
that's why stopping the boats is my top
priority
it's why the Prime Minister made
stopping the boats one of his five
promises to the British people and it's
why according to the opinion polls the
British people back this government's
bill
[Applause]
buy more than two to one
this does not mean Mr debtor speaker as
some assert that the British people are
xenophobic
since 2015 the British people have
provided Refuge to nearly half a million
people through Global safe and legal
routes
the British people are fair
compassionate and generous
millions millions of legal migrants
including my parents have experienced
this warmth first hand
but the British people are also
realistic
they know that our capacity to help
people is not Unlimited
since 2018 some 85 000 people
Secretary of State for giving way does
she think the British public went to see
pregnant women and children detained an
immigration detention centers I do not
believe for a minute they do but that's
what's in this bill
the British people want to see people to
they want to stop people dying on the
channel
that's what this is about
it's naive to suggest
that it's lawful and appropriate to make
this journey people are dying and we
need to stop it
since 2018 some 85 000 people illegally
entered the United Kingdom by small boat
45 000 of them last year alone they have
overwhelmed our Asylum system
local authorities simply do not have the
housing or the public service capacity
to support everyone the British taxpayer
to the lady
I thank the Home Secretary for giving
away
thank the Home Secretary for giving way
so early in Her speech has is she
satisfied personally that there is
enough provision for vulnerable children
in the proposals that she's putting
forward tonight
it's in detail but yes vulnerable people
will be receiving appropriate
safeguarding and Welfare support
the British taxpayer cannot continue to
Fork out six million pounds a day on
hotels to house illegal arrivals now
let's be honest the vast majority of
arrivals 74 in 2021 were adult males
under the age of 40. the vast majority
were not pregnant women the vast
majority were not young children all
traveled through safe countries like
France in which they could and should
have first claimed Asylum many many came
directly from safe countries like
Albania
and that and when we try to remove them
they turn our generous Asylum laws
against us to thwart removal
this is
thank you um this is my right honorable
friend for giving away does she agree
that when 70 labor MPS including the
leader in the opposition saying a letter
comparing for the release of dangerous
foreign criminals who we want to remove
from the UK they expose themselves as
pro-open borders and unlimited
immigration and put themselves on the
side of the criminal rather than the
silence
[Applause]
my honorable friend puts it very well
what we have here is naive do-gooders
who would rather campaign to prevent the
removal of a foreign National offender
one of whom went on to tragically kill
another then vote in favor of our
measures that would have toughened up
the sanctions on foreign National
offenders I'm going to make some
progress
the reality is Mr Deputy speaker is that
this system is simply unfair it's unfair
on the most vulnerable
it's unfair on those who play by the
rules it's unfair on the British people
so we must change the law and we must
stop the boats
now Mr Speaker for too long those of us
voicing concerns about the effects of
uncontrolled unprecedented and illegal
migration have been accused of
inflammatory rhetoric
but nothing
nothing is more likely to inflame
tensions than ignoring the Public's
reasonable concerns about the current
situation
the public are neither stupid nor
bigoted
they can see firsthand the impact on
their communities and it's irresponsible
to suggest otherwise
and speaking of acting responsibly Mr
Deputy speaker I want to put something
on the record
it's perfectly respectable
for a child of immigrants like me to say
that I'm deeply grateful to live here
to say that immigration has been
overwhelmingly good for the United
Kingdom but that we've had too much of
it in recent years and to say and to say
and to say that uncontrolled and illegal
migration is simply bad
I'm grateful to my right Uncle friend
does she agree with me that in the last
couple of years where we've seen
exponential growth in this human
trafficking coming across the channel
that actually what's happening is the
money that people who can ill afford to
spend on these criminals is being used
to make their trade even more effective
putting yet more lives in danger
my right normal friend puts it very well
we have now a sophisticated
well-resourced multi-billion pound trade
of illegal people smuggling in human
trafficking it is pan-national and it
needs to stop
but to say
I'm going to make progress
um
it is and yet Mr Electric speaker like
despite our reasonable concerns that we
have raised on several occasions like my
rightful friend the member for Whitton
before me I am subject to the most
grotesque slurs for saying such simple
truths about the impact of unlimited and
illegal migration the worst among them
poisoned by the extreme ideology of
identity politics suggests that a
person's skin color should dictate their
political views Mr Speaker Mr I will not
be hectured by out of touch lefties or
anyone
be
patronized I won't be characterized on
what appropriate
for someone of my background can hold
and I will not back down when faced with
spurious accusations of bigotry
Mr Deputy speaker
when such smears seep into the discourse
of this chamber as they did last week
accusations that this government's
policies policies backed by the majority
of the British people are bigoted are
bigoted are xenophobic or a dog whistles
to racists it is irresponsible and
frankly beneath the Dignity of this
place
politicians of all Stripes should know
better
and they should choose their words
carefully
[Music]
[Applause]
Deputy speak
criticism to this bill in moral terms
ignore certain truths firstly they
ignore that we have a moral duty to stop
the boats people are dying in the
channel they are taking Journeys that
are unsafe unnecessary and unlawful
point of order
sure you'll agree with the Home
Secretary that we should all in this
debate choose our words carefully so
what part of carefully
does her statement about an invasion uh
constitute and the right honorable
ladies exaggeration by the use of the
word explanation exponential
there again I think on this particular
case it is a matter for the individual
person making the speech all I'm going
to say right at this outset though is
clearly this is a very emotive subject
that we're dealing with and I'd ask
everybody to use temperate language
rather than inflaming the situation
that's already there
we leave it there Home Secretary
yes I appreciate your instruction to all
our colleagues
Mr Deputy speaker the way to stop these
deaths is to stop the boat
secondly the critics ignore that our
policy does in fact guarantee
humanitarian protection for those who
genuinely need it our policy is
profoundly and at heart a Humane attempt
to break the incentive that sustains the
business model of the smuggling gangs
people pay thousands of pounds to make
these Journeys to the UK
they're for giving way I uh as the
secretary probably knows chair of the
appg for freedom of religious belief uh
we have many people from across the
world who are persecuted discriminated
who are abused physically and have to
leave their countries some of those
sectors did as you will know yourself
are living in countries and it's taken
so long for their process for their
applications to be so they can actually
get here I know the secret probably
shares my opinion that it's important
that those who are true are Cinema
Seekers get their opportunity to come
here Candace said assure me and assure
this house that those who are personated
those who are discriminated will have
their opportunity of coming here for
Asylum
well we have a very proud and extensive
tradition of offering Refuge to hundreds
of thousands of people who apply
according to our system and apply
according to our criteria and I'm very
proud of the Refuge and security that
we've provided to those people fleeing
the very circumstances to which he
refers
by ensuring Mr Deputy speaker that
people do not remain here we are
removing their incentive to make the
journey in the first place but crucially
if people are truly in need of
protection They will receive protection
in Rwanda now critics overwhelmingly
fail feel to acknowledge this fact let's
be clear Rwanda is a dynamic country
with a thriving economy I've enjoyed
visiting myself twice before and I look
forward to visiting again
very grateful to the Home Secretary is
she also worried that the criminal gangs
that are exploiting people in this
Dreadful way at Great profit may also be
linked to other types of serious crime
and helping Finance other
destabilization
afraid he raises a very uh worrying fact
about what we are seeing and when I've
spoken to police Chiefs around the
country what they tell me is that
criminality in particular drug Supply
and usage is now connected to people who
came here on small boats illegally in
the first place thirdly
[Music]
but but Rwanda is a fundamentally safe
country Mr Deputy speaker as affirmed by
the high court it's got a proud track
record of helping the world's most
vulnerable including refugees for the
United Nations
and thirdly
in Rwanda people who are same-sex
attracted and trans people are not
covered by anti-discrimination laws does
she think that makes it a safe country
for gay people and trans people
yeah well well I'm sure that my
honorable friend has read the Judgment
from the high court which is an
exhaustive it's an exhaustive analysis
and an authoritative analysis by senior
and learner judges in the high court and
they look at the compliance of our
Rwanda our world leading Rwanda
partnership with International
obligations including the convention on
human rights and the refugee convention
it has been deemed to be lawful and a
proper partnership and I prefer her to
the Judgment of the court I'm going to
have to make some progress I've taken
quite a lot of interventions I'm afraid
thirdly Mr Deputy speaker critics like
on one life
[Applause]
I'm very grateful to the Home Secretary
and I do find it odd that so many
members opposite are trying their best
to trip her up on a policy which is
incredibly important to every community
in this country and Mr Deputy speaker
although they will try and Shout me down
let me say that in my constituency of
Gloucester which is a happy cohesive
multiracial multi-ethnic Society with a
primary school of over 50 different
nationalities I know because I speak to
them that most of the minority ethnic
communities are very sensitive to
getting this issue of balance right
because if we get it wrong the backlash
will be felt by them more than anyone
else not by SNP MPS who don't have
Asylum seekers in their constituency
all right
[Music]
order
not just temperate language I want
temperate Behavior point of order
thank you very much Mr addiction speaker
I'm very grateful to make this point of
order I wonder if it's possible if you
can maybe advise on how we can correct
the record on this actually perplexing
and I fully misleading statement that
the member opposite has made which is
profoundly unhelpful in the context of
this debate to that point of order
Richard Graham Mr Deputy speaker no one
in this house wishes to cause any
offense and if I have done so of course
I apologize
two hotels full of Asylum Seekers and I
would be very interested to know how
many hotels full of Asylum Seekers are
the members
order before we resume just want to put
a couple of points out here number one
interventions are now eating into the
amount of time that's going to be
allotted to people so uh people just
simply aren't going to get in in the
debate that's that's the first one and
points of order are also doing exactly
the same so all I would caution
is make sure that the points of order
are for the chair if they are going to
be used and please
and well the answer is as you know that
members are responsible for their own
contributions and if anything is uh said
that is untoward they should correct the
record at the earliest opportunity which
I believe Mr Graham has done Home
Secretary well can I just agree
wholeheartedly what my honorable friend
said he's absolutely right and if we
don't well he's right about Scotland
that until recently was only Glasgow who
was taking Asylum Seekers and when
compared to the other nations of the
United Kingdom they have taken a
disproportionately low number
[Applause]
that we face as a country harmonious
happy with ourselves cohesive if that if
we don't deal with this problem uh then
we really uh will face serious problems
about Community tension and Community
cohesion I'm going to make some progress
I know that a lot of people want to get
them but a lot of people want to make
contributions to the debate
on top of that the small boats crisis
demonstrates that there are countless
more there are countless uh there are
100 million people who are displaced
globally that is confirmed by the United
Nations and our critics pretend
simultaneously that the United Kingdom
doesn't have any safe Global uh safe and
legal routes and that these routes
should also be Unlimited
the small boats crisis demonstrates that
there are countless more economic
migrants willing to take a chance to
come here in search of a better life
how many of those do the benches
opposite think it will take to stop the
boats they haven't been able to provide
an answer because the reality is Mr
Deputy speaker those arguing for open
borders via unlimited safe and legal
routes are of course they are of course
entitled to do so but they should do so
honestly they shouldn't try to deceive
the public Mr Deputy speaker by dressing
up what is an extreme political argument
in the fake Garb of humanitarianism
no Mr Deputy speaker nor should they
pretend that the UK doesn't have Global
safe and legal routes in recent years
our country specific routes have
provided refuge for 150 000 people
leaving autocracy in Hong Kong 160
000 ukrainians fleeing Putin's horrific
war and 25 000 Afghans escaping the
Taliban another 50 000 people have come
to the UK via routes open to people from
any country those include those include
the UK resettlement scheme which
includes Community sponsorship the
Mandate resettlement scheme and
crucially if someone has a qualifying
family member in the UK the family
reunion route
Mr Deputy speaker we are proud We are
proud of those safe and legal routes and
when we stop the boats we will look to
expand them
now this bill introduces an annual cap
determined by Parliament on the number
of refugees the UK will resettle via
safe and legal routes this will ensure
an orderly system considering local
Authority capacity for housing public
services and support
Mr Speaker the illegal migration Bill
enables the Detention of illegal
arrivals without bail or judicial review
within the first 28 days of detention we
can maintain detention thereafter under
current laws so long as we have a
reasonable Prospect of removal this
reflects the existing common law
position consistent with Article 5 of
the echr the bill places a duty on the
Home Secretary to remove one moment the
bill places a duty on the Home Secretary
to remove illegal entrance and
significantly Narrows the number of
challenges and appeals that can suspend
removal
I thank the Home Secretary for giving
away the last Home Secretary said anyone
who arrives illegally will be deemed
inadmissible and either be returned to
the country they arrive from or a third
safe country they considered 18 000
people inadmissible to the UK Asylum
system as a result and just 21 people
were returned that is just naught point
one percent
what has changed in this bill and what
percentage of those that she deems
inadmissible does she expect to return
well I think I've got to also correctly
lady on a kind of fallacy that she's
operating under we are returning people
who don't have a legal basis to be in
this country there are many ways to look
at the numbers since the prime
minister's announcement for example
we've returned 600 people back to
Albania last year alone we returned 14
000 people so it's a fallacy to suggest
that there are no returns and that we're
somehow not removing people who don't
have a right to be here but moving on Mr
Deputy speaker only those under 18
medically unfit to fly or at real risk
of serious and irreversible harm will be
able to delay their removal any other
claims will be heard remotely after
removal
Mr Deputy speaker when our world leading
modern slavery Act passed the impact
Assessment envisaged 3 500 referrals a
year that act of parliament was a was
humble friend could give a point of
clarification she's implied that people
are going to be unable to claim Asylum
here in the UK and will be removed
immediately or at least potentially
after 28 days detention paragraph 5.1 of
the memorandum of understanding with
Rwanda requires the United Kingdom to be
responsible for the initial screening of
Asylum Seekers could she perhaps explain
what that screening will be if it won't
be screening acclaim
well we have a very extensive system of
screening all of those people who arrive
in the UK via small boats that is
effectively what our manston Center is
designed for people undergo Security
checks and biometric checks and any
other identity checks and that screening
uh process is something that we
undertaking sense over here
Mr Deputy speaker
when our world leading I I'm sorry I'm
gonna have to make some progress when
our world leading modern slavery Act
passed the impact assessment and Visage
3500 referrals a year
that act of parliament was an important
step forward in protecting vulnerable
people from the abuses of human
trafficking and modern slavery it's
something of which I'm incredibly proud
but last year there were 17
000 referrals which took on average 543
days to consider I'll have to give you a
moment the most referred nationality in
2022 were from citizens of Albania a
safe European country a NATO Ally and a
signatory of the European convention
against trafficking in 2021 73 of people
who were detained for removal put
forward a modern slavery claim compared
to just three percent of those not in
detention and what we've also seen is a
number of foreign National offenders who
after serving their sentences for some
of the most despicable crimes like
murder and rape have on the point of
removal put in a last-minute claim of
modern slavery to thwart their
deportation the fact is Mr Deputy
speaker that a modern slavery laws are
being abused
to to this exact point I wonder if the
Home Secretary could tell this house how
many of that 17
000 increase has been made up of British
people including British children who
until this year made up the largest
group of people who have increased in
the numbers so those are British
children can I also ask her to just
point out to the house exactly who makes
the referrals into the human trafficking
system in our country is it in fact
under the auspices of her the Home
Secretary and the home office or can
people just claim it or is it actually
her office who have to say whether they
can
well what we've seen is that a large and
growing proportion of modern slavery
claims have been made by people who have
arrived here illegally and as I just
refer to people who are foreign National
offenders people who have served their
criminal sentences who upon the point of
removal have put in a last minute modern
slavery claim precisely to thwart their
quotation and also it is all we we work
very closely with local authorities and
other bodies to ensure that referrals
are made into the mechanism
why this that this is why the bill will
disqualify illegal entrance from using
modern slavery rules in this way Mr
Deputy speaker given the
mischaracterization of the bill from
Members opposite I'd like to make a few
things clear the home secretary's duty
to remove will not be applied to detain
and remove unaccompanied Asylum seeking
children consistent with current policy
only in limited circumstances such as
for the purposes of family reunion we
will remove
unaccompanied Asylum seeking children
from the UK
otherwise they will be provided with the
necessary support in the UK until they
reach 18. with respect to the removal of
families and pregnant women it Bears
repeating that the overwhelming majority
of illegal arrivals are adult men under
the age of 40. removing them will be our
primary focus but we must not create
incentives for the Smugglers to focus on
with to focus on people with particular
characteristics by signposting
exemptions for removal
it is right that we retain powers to
adapt our policy so that we can respond
to any change in tactics by the
smuggling gangs Mr Deputy speaker those
critics who say this bill will be found
to be unlawful said the same thing about
our partnership with Rwanda
a high court disagreed
some of the nation's finest legal Minds
have been and continue to be involved in
its development
the UK will always seek to uphold
international law and we are confident
that this bill will deliver what is
necessary within those parameters
section 19 of the Human Rights Act
requires ministers to give a view on the
level of legal certainty on a Bill's
compliance with the echr this is a
unique UK requirement not part of the
echr itself a section 191b statement is
today Deputy speaker simply means that
we are unable to say decisively that
this bill is compatible with the echr it
is clear that there are good Arguments
for compatibility but that some of the
Bill's measures are novel and legally
untested
the bat the bench's opposite seem to
forget that section 19 1B statements
were made by the labor governments on
the communications act 2003 and by the
lib Dems for the house of laws Reform
Bill in 2012. it didn't mean that those
bills were unlawful and it doesn't mean
that this one is either
claims that this bill will breach our
Refugee convention obligations are
simply fatuous the convention obliges
parties to provide protection to those
seeking Refuge it does not require that
this protection be in the UK illegal
arrivals requiring protection will
receive it in a safe Third Country such
as Rwanda moreover article 31 of the
convention is clear that individuals may
be removed if they don't come directly
from the territory where their freedom
is threatened
denying access to the UK's Asylum system
to those arriving illegally from France
or any other safe country in which they
could have claimed Asylum is therefore
entirely consistent with the spirit and
the letter of the convention Mr Deputy
speaker the opposition say that this
bill cannot work because we lack the
capacity to detain all small boat
arrivals we are expanding detention
capacity with two new immigration
removal centers but clearly we are not
building capacity to detain 40 000
people
nor do we need to
the aim of this bill is not to detain
people but to swiftly remove them
Australia achieved success against a
similar problem of illegal Maritime
migration they reduced annual crossings
from twenty thousand to hundreds in a
matter of months in large part by
operationalizing Swift Third Country
removals they didn't need tens of
thousands of detention places either if
we can demonstrate to people willing to
pay thousands of pounds to illegally
enter the UK that there is a reasonable
prospect that they will be detained and
removed we are confident that Crossings
will reduce significantly
additionally Mr Deputy speaker arguments
that our approach cannot work because
Rwanda lacks capacity are wrong let me
be clear our partnership with Rwanda is
uncapped We Stand ready to
operationalize it at scale as soon as is
legally practicable
it is understandable that Rwanda has not
procured thousands of beds to
accommodate arrivals while legal
challenges are ongoing
so the Home Secretary has just admitted
that Rwanda doesn't have thousands of
places she will know that the rounding
government has talked about taking a few
hundred people she will also know that
the Rwanda high court agreement says
that cases need to be individualized and
yet she is expecting to find locations
for tens of thousands of people expected
to arrive this year she has no returns
agreement with France or any other
European country so where is she
expecting to send the tens of thousands
of people expected to arrive in the UK
this year
really read our agreement with Rwanda
before she makes a comment like that
because if she did read it she would see
and if she read the Judgment from the
high court she'd see both at our
agreement with around it is lawful and
proper and compliant with our
International produce but also that it
is uncapped and potentially Rwanda could
accommodate High numbers of people that
we seek to relocate them Rwanda has the
capacity to resettle tens of thousands
of people if necessary Mr Deputy speaker
critics of this government's plan to
stop the boats would have more
credibility if they offered up a plan of
Their Own
now the opposition say let's look at
what the opposition plan is they would
increase the funding to the NCAA to
disrupt trafficking Upstream never mind
that the government's already doubled
the funding for the NCA precisely for
that purpose the oppositions say that
they would go harder on the people
Smugglers never mind that labor voted
against our nationality and borders at
which introduced life sentences for
people Smugglers
about establishing a cross-channel task
force never mind that we've already set
up a small boat operational command with
over 700 new staff working hand in hand
with the French the opposition say that
they would get a new agreement with the
French never mind that just last week
our prime minister struck a historic
multi-year deal with the French to
increase the number of Jean dams
patrolling the French beaches the
opposition say we should do more with
Partners around the world never mind
that this government has returned
agreements with Albania Georgia Serbia
Nigeria India Pakistan and Serbia and as
for our world leading agreement with
Rwanda well we all know what the
opposition would do about that they
would scrap it the oppositions say that
this government can't be trusted with
our borders Mr Deputy speaker but the
fact is that the leader of the
opposition and some 70 odd 70 odd labor
MPS a third a third of their
parliamentary party signed letters
signed letters to stop the dangerous
foreign criminals being kicked out of
Britain one of whom tragically went on
to kill another person in the UK a
shameful day for the labor party
how
how easy it is for the opposition to say
never mind the British public believing
that they know better arrogantly
dismissively the truth is Mr Deputy
speaker they don't have a plan but you
know what's even worse they don't
actually care that they don't have a
plan
if they listened if they listened they
would hear a clear reasonable and
resounding message from the British
people
it would be that we like controlled
immigration we welcome genuine refugees
but we do not want uncontrolled or
illegal migration enough is enough stop
the boats
[Music]
that's Mr Deputy speaker is the call
from the British people that is their
cry for action on all of us who serve
them in this place
Mr Deputy speaker this is a government
that listens it listens to the people
and aided by this bill we will stop the
boats
the question is that the bill will be
now read a second time and I'm calling
Yvette Cooper to move the amendment
[Applause]
Mr Deputy speaker I Rise to move the
reasoned amendments in the name of the
leader of the opposition
Mr Deputy speaker most people want to
see strong border security and a
properly managed and controlled fair and
firm Asylum and Refugee system so we
have proper grip along our borders and
so we also do our bit alongside other
countries to help those fleeing
persecution and conflict
that is what labor believes in
but right now after 13 years of
conservative government we have none of
those things
our border security undermined because
they let the criminal Smuggler and
trafficking gangs rip and the Asylum
system in chaos letting everyone down
and all they can offer is this bill
which makes all of those problems worse
last year 45 000 people traveled on
dangerous small boats up from just 284
years ago as criminal gangs making 180
million pounds a year from putting lives
at risk yet over the same period
convictions of people Smugglers have
halved
a massive increase in The Gangs
operating along the channel
a massive drop in the number of
criminals caught
and still refusing to go after the gangs
and the deputy chair of the conservative
party thinking we shouldn't even bother
I'll give way to The Honorable member if
he will now support our proposals
oh my God
for a cross-border police unit to go
after the criminal gangs
the question
um I was wondering if we went would
explain to me why it was that the leader
of the opposition wanted human rights
lawyer that there's an undertone of
racism in all immigration law does he
continue to believe that
Mr Deputy speaker immigration law is
important but the problem is at the
moment huge amounts of immigration law
isn't even enforced they have had an 80
percent drop in the number of people who
have been unsuccessful in the Asylum
system and have not been returned at 80
percent drop since the conservatives
came to office Mr Deputy speaker at the
same time our Asylum system under the
Tories is in total chaos only one
percent of last year's cases have even
had an initial decision home office
decision making cut by 40 percent the
backlog trebled in the space of just a
few years and thousands of people in
costly and inappropriate hotels
I will give way
grateful to the right honorable lady for
giving away I'm also very grateful to
her for the kind comments she made about
me in her interview over the weekend in
modern slavery work
um she has just referred to the backlog
in Asylum cases if she thinks the
current figure means the system is in
chaos then what was her description of
the system under the labor government of
which she was a member which had
backlogging Asylum cases of between 400
and 450 it's true
the
um the former prime minister and former
Home Secretary is uh experienced enough
to know that is not an accurate
characterization of what happened
your government left office the backlog
of initial decisions was just a few
thousand now
it is
and
and 60 000 and in fact has trebled in
the last few years as a result of the
complete failure by the conservative
benches I I do you know what I actually
I I'm gonna have to give way again to
the um to the former prime minister
because she and I have have asked each
other questions over so many years that
I will have to give away to her again
I'm grateful to the right honorable lady
does she not accept that between the
late 1990s and the early 2000s when
labor was in government the number of
back of Asylum cases that were in the
Legacy the backlog Rose to between 400
and 450 000.
so the important point that the
made
that the former prime minister addresses
is that in the late 90s there was an
issue about what happened with the
Bosnian Refugee crisis and many others
but in fact it was the action that the
last Labor government took exactly
they've got a grip of the system and
addressed some of the challenges and
took action in order to make sure that
we could have both border security and a
system that provides for refugees and
for those in need of asylum
and what the homes former Home Secretary
will also know
because she was responsible for bringing
in the modern slavery law which I
supported when she did
was that this bill also rips up many of
the provisions at the heart of that
modern slavery legislation and what I
hope she and I would agree on is that it
should be possible for our country to
have strong border security to have
strong measures and fast effective
measures that at the moment the
government does not have to deal with
Asylum cases swiftly and speedily and
also make provision for those who have
fled persecution and conflict and
provide support for those who have been
trafficked and those who are the victims
of modern slavery and I hope that she
will agree with me that this bill does
the total opposite of that
friend forgiving way and does she
ET members of said talk about a labor
government 13 years ago and does she
like me wonder why this government
having been in charge for 13 years
continuously likes to look all the way
back rather than addressing their own
failures
see well my boyfriend is right that they
have to take responsibility for 13 years
in government 13 years in which we have
now seen refugees left in limbo even
though they have fled persecution and
conflict those who are not refugees and
have no right to be here not returned
never returned an 80 drop in returns of
unsuccessful Asylum Seekers and at the
same time a 40 drop in Refugee family
reunion visas the Afghan resettlement
scheme shamefully Frozen and children
left with no way to rejoin family and
time and again ministers just want to
blame someone else all the members of
the conservative party just wants to
blame someone else but they have been in
charge for the last 13 years they keep
telling us the Asylum system is broken
well seriously who broke it
[Applause]
we need urgent action to stop the
dangerous Boat Crossings that are
putting lives at risk and undermining
our border security but this bill is a
con that makes the chaos worse
it won't do the things the Prime
Minister and the Home Secretary have
promised it won't stop the criminal
gangs or dangerous Crossings and in fact
it makes it easier for those gangs as
well it won't return everyone in fact it
makes it harder to get return agreements
it won't clear the Asylum backlog in
fact it will mean tens of thousands more
people in Asylum accommodation and
hotels it won't deliver controlled and
manage safe Alternatives instead it will
cut them back and it will rip up our
long-standing commitment to
international law
and it will lock up children it will
lock up children remove support and safe
refuges from women who have been
trafficked and it will deny citizenship
for people like Mo Farah
the last law that they passed on this
just nine months ago made everything
worse it's all dangerous Crossings go up
delays go up and now they are seriously
expecting us to do all the same things
again
um the UK was one of the instigators of
the 1951 Refugee convention that's
because before the war the UK government
failed to allow Jews into this country
fleeing the persecution of the Nazis the
British Board of Jewish deputies this
week said today's British Jewish
Community Center from refugees we have
significance concerns of potential newly
proposed legislation to breach the
refugee convention do you not agree with
me that we could be in breach of the
convention if we pass this today and be
in breach of international law and our
own legacy in this area
well my honorable friend is right and
these are damning words we've heard from
the board of deputies and from many
other organizations about the impact
that this legislation will have
and at the heart of it
there is a con
because the Prime Minister has pledged
that anyone who arrives in the UK
without the right papers will be
detained and swiftly removed no ifs no
buts but where to
so not to France because
the Prime Minister failed to get a
returns agreement failed with other
countries as well and this bill makes it
harder to get return agreements because
it undermines compliance with the
international laws and standards that
those other countries are committed to
uphold standards that we used to be
committed to uphold as well
nor to Rwanda either
the Home Secretary has admitted already
that that is failing the taxpayers
already written 140 million pound check
the home office says it is unenforceable
with a high risk of Fraud and no
evidence of a deterrent effect the
Israel Rwanda deal increased trafficking
rather than reducing it and most the
Rwandan authorities say they might take
a couple of hundred people put 45 000
people arrived last year and the
immigration Minister shakes his head but
he said in a statement in December in
this house the initial promise was to
receive 200 people and that the further
preparations had not been made I will
give I will give I will give wait I will
give way first to my honorable friend
grateful and I'm also pleased with the
moderate way that she is putting a very
sound argument in absolute contrast to
the rhetoric that we got from the Home
Secretary she hits I think a really
important nail on the head on the front
of the bill we have the statement of the
Home Secretary that she cannot uh
certify that the provisions of the bill
are compatible with convention rights
and yet schedule
a schedule of the bill uh countries or
territories to which a person may be
removed include fellow signatories of
the European convention on human rights
what legal advice has she seen that we
will be able to do that or that they
will accept returns from the United
Kingdom
well the mobile phone makes a really
important point because in order to have
cooperation be it on return agreements
be it on alternative arrangements for
processing all of those things there
needs to be proper standards in place
and those have to be standards that
other countries will respect in order to
make agreements with us and therefore
pulling away from the European
convention on human rights makes those
agreements more difficult despite the
fact that in fact it's having those
International intercrements in place
that is one of the most important things
to dealing with the challenges we face
I will give way to The Honorable member
and they'll give them I'm grateful to
her for giving away does she show my
deep concern about the placeholder
Clause 49 that seeks to legislate to
ignore echr interim orders lodged
against this government's inhumane
morally a borrowed plans in order to get
around the fact that what the government
is doing is in not compatible with our
conventional obligations does she agree
that that actually will undermine our
Global standing and make it that much
harder to make any kind of returns
agreements or anything else as she
describes here here I think this adds to
really the chaos that there is within
this piece of legislation that the
government hasn't even worked out what
it is that it wants to do and as a
consequence of which is undermining our
reputation to be the kind of country
that stands up for the rule of law and
that leads the way in expecting other
countries to follow the law and other
countries to do their bit as well our
giveaway to The Honorable member up
there who's been very patient and will
then make some more progress before I
take further interventions because I am
conscious Mr Deputy speaker of the time
Shadow Home Secretary for giving way and
as is her right she's outlining her
objection to this piece of legislation
she asked my honorable friend the member
for Ipswich Ipswich whether he would
back her proposals could she do the
house a favor and actually outline her
proposals or is this another example of
her consistently opposing but not coming
up with any fresh ideas for herself
he did very happy to I hope that the
honorable member will support our
proposal for a cross-border police unit
in order to go after the criminal gangs
and get those convictions UPS which had
totally collapsed on the conservatives
watch I hope too will support our
proposals for a fast track for Albania
and other safe countries which again the
ministers are not doing well this is
interesting because the the immigration
Minister says oh we're already doing it
except that they're not except that
they're not only one percent of the
cases from Albania have been decided in
fact the home office is not taking Fast
Track decisions on safe countries like
Albania for all of the promises they
made even where they have the powers to
take action they're not doing it I hope
he will also support our proposals to
work on not just return agreements with
France and other countries but also
family reunion arrangements and reforms
to resettlement schemes in order to make
those work as well but instead what
we've got is a bill which is a con a
bill which actually will make things
worse Mr Liberty speaker we've been
clear that they're the Home Secretary
has nowhere to explain that she is going
to return people to and last year they
made exactly the same promises when they
said 18 000 people would be inadmissible
because they had traveled through safe
countries yet just 21 people were
returned of those that the Home
Secretary said were inadmissible just 21
are returned now she wants to say that
everyone is inadmissible but if she
still has just not .1 of those that she
actually manages to return the reality
is she will have tens of thousands of
people who she is simply creating a con
creating uh misinformation and conning
all of those on her back benches who
have been cheering for the things that
she says and then we'll see it unravel
in practice now the Home Secretary says
it means that she can return people to
designated safe countries like Albania
she can do that already she doesn't need
this law to do that she's already got
the power to fast-track Albania in other
cases we've been calling for it for
months the unhcr proposed it two years
ago the Prime Minister even promised it
before Christmas but it is not happening
99 of those cases are still in limbo and
just 15 people who had previously
arrived in small boats were returned
last month that is the equivalent of 180
a year when over ten thousand people
came from the designated safe country of
Albania the real problem is that home
office ministers conservative home
office ministers just don't have any
grip on the system that they are
supposed to be in charge of I will give
away to The Honorable I'm a member but I
have one more and then I need to make
some progress Shadow homes actually
giving away from Step speaker my focus
goes back to what was already mentioned
which is Clause 49 which is looking
specifically at interim measures from
the strasbour court which no have no
actually affecting UK law but UK courts
may take them into effect when they're
passing their own judgments would the
shadow Home Secretary and the labor
party support me in wanting to see this
particular Clause beefed up and actually
making sure that the Home Secretary is
under a statutory duty to uh to remove
unlawful migrants
well I um I think she he perhaps should
have put that question to the Home
Secretary because he appears to disagree
with his own conservative government
policy and be off on another bit of
freelancing for himself further
undermining I would say any possibility
of getting International agreements
whether it's on returns or anything else
he is planning to make it even harder to
get the kinds of returns agreements we
need and to get the kind of
international cooperation we need as
well yeah yeah ministers say they plan
to lock everyone up before they are
returned and the bill says everyone is
included children
unaccompanied teenagers pregnant women
torture victims
trafficking victims
people like Afghan interpreters or young
Hong kongers who we promised to help
locked up because they arrive without
the right papers
the Home Secretary hasn't said where or
how long before it's possible at Raf
Scranton although the Tory members for
Gainsborough doesn't want that possibly
at mod weatherfield but the touring
member for Braintree Hirsch her cabinet
colleague the foreign secretary also
doesn't want that there might in other
circumstances be pressure on the Home
Secretary to put it in her own
constituency except for the fact that
she doesn't actually have one right now
I will give way to The Honorable member
if you are a responsible opposition you
have to have a plan we all agree we've
got to stop these boats their plan
appears to be to process Asylum
applications even more quickly so more
people will come or process them in
France where an unlimited number want to
come all this ridiculous idea of a
cross-border police force everybody
knows that on average you get caught
once on the beaches by the French police
you are not detained you come back the
very next night they all get there she
knows perfectly well that the only way
we're going to stop these boats is the
government plan and to detain them and
at the board of giranda
it's only 200 of them
the The Honorable member is just kidding
himself if he thinks any of the
government's plan is actually going to
happen
if he thinks that it's actually going to
work
Clause 9 Mr Deputy speaker Clause 9 says
what happens to all of these people who
cannot be returned to the tens of
thousands of people who will arrive are
expected to arrive according to the
government since the seventh the uh 7th
of March what will happen to them Clause
9 says the home office will provide them
with accommodation and support in other
words they will go back into Asylum
accommodation and hotels but they just
won't ever get an asylum decision so
tens of thousands of people every year
will be added to the home office backlog
only this is going to be a permanent
backlog that they aren't ever even going
to try and clear those who would have
been returned after their Asylum claim
was refused now will not be and those
who would have been granted Sanctuary
will be stuck in limbo instead tens of
thousands of people just added to the
Asylum backlog costing billions of
pounds more up to 25 billion pounds over
the next five years and as for that Club
the Prime Minister promised to clear
it's going to get worse not better
because effectively all they've
concluded is that the Tory home office
is so rubbish at taking any Asylum
decisions on time they've decided to
just stop doing them all together and
they are hoping that no one will notice
and Mr Speaker last week I said Mr
Deputy speaker last week I said that the
government might have decided not to
call this an asylum system anymore but
everyone was still going to be in the
system nevertheless well I got that
wrong
because I've read the explanatory notes
again and it says subsection 2 amends
section 94 of the 99 act so that the
term Asylum Seeker covers those whose
Asylum claims are inadmissible by virtue
of clause 4 of this bill so in other
words they're amending the law so that
all the people who they are going to
exclude from the Asylum system are still
going to be called Asylum Seekers after
all and still going to be in the Asylum
system so you couldn't make this up more
chaos more people in the Asylum system
even fewer decisions taken more people
detained with nowhere to detain them and
more people stuck in limbo and no one
credibly believing that any of this is
going to act as any kind of deterrent to
any of the criminal gangs at all they
are chasing headlines but it's all a
huge con and what is the price of that
con what is the price of those empty
headlines of cancel Asylum decisions
rather than getting a grip the damaging
our International standing and our
chance of getting new cooperation
agreements to tackle the problems and
our commitments to the rule of law
saying you've written uniquely won't
take Asylum decisions yet expecting
other countries to keep doing so saying
that Britain uniquely won't follow the
refugee convention or the trafficking
convention or the European convention on
human rights yet urging other countries
to follow them
and think two of the price for the
people we promise to help for the Afghan
interpreters who worked for our Armed
Forces but who missed the last flight
out of Kabul and who the government told
to find an alternative route if they
arrive in the UK now the conservatives
plan to lock them up keep them in limbo
and treat them as forever illegal in the
country that they made huge sacrifices
to help
or the Ukrainian family who traveled
here via Ireland as I know some people
did in the early days of the conflict
without the right papers it could have
been the family staying with me or the
family staying with the immigration
minister
I've listened to teenagers talking about
how they had 20 minutes to pack before
they fled their homes not knowing if
they would ever return or see friends
and family again
but under this law
those teenagers who arrived with the
wrong papers would be locked up
denied any chance to ever live or work
here lawfully in the future that is the
Tories position
so in the interests of a plan that is
actually a con and that won't even work
won't even work to deter the criminal
gangs won't even work to remove people
because they don't have the returns
agreements in place will make it harder
to get those returns agreements in
exchange for that con that makes nothing
any better
they believe that no one who arrives in
Britain without the right papers in
their hands should ever be able to seek
protection here or live here no matter
what their personal circumstances
now consider what I will give work I
will give way but then I will make I'm
most grateful for the honorable lady for
giving away
which parts of France are such that
people need to flee from France to seek
refuge in this country
[Applause]
well as the honorable member will know
the majority of people who are seeking
Asylum who arrive in France stay in
France rather than seeking to travel to
the UK but we believe that we should be
seeking to get a returns agreement with
France alongside new Arrangements on
things like family reunion but at the
moment the government has so undermined
its relationship with France and other
European countries that it has totally
failed to get any of those agreements in
place and it is making it harder with
this bill so if he believes that returns
Agreements are needed if he believes
that new alternative Arrangements around
family reunion or other things are
needed he should oppose this bill
because this bill will make it harder to
get any of those agreements in place
because it is undermining International
cooperation and international law that
all of those other countries depend on
so consider what it means for the young
Vietnamese woman who has been repeat
who's been trafficked into sexual
exploitation
repeatedly raped and beaten by criminal
gangs who brought her here and who
control and dictate her life
under this bill if the police find her
when they bust the brothel she won't be
able to get modern slavery support
anymore won't be able to go to a safe
house or get help from the Salvation
Army
instead she'll just be locked up in one
of the home office detention centers
if she cooperates with the police for a
bit she might get some temporary support
but if that police investigation is
closed would her world comes crashing
down again
and here's what the Prime Minister
tweeted about all of that
if you come to the UK illegally you
can't benefit from our modern slavery
protections you will be denied
denied access to the UK's modern slavery
system
now think on that bringing people into
the UK illegally in order to control and
exploit them is exactly what trafficking
is cross-border trafficking is by
definition a major form of modern
slavery yet this government is just
proposing to wish it away to exclude it
entirely from the modern slavery system
as if the very fact of of Crossing
Borders somehow stopped it being slavery
at all the message from the UK
government to the criminal trafficking
and trafficking and slavery gangs is
this don't worry so long as you bring
people into the country illegally we
won't help them in fact we will help you
if that is their message to the criminal
gowns we will help you out we will
threaten those people with immediate
detention and deportation so that you
can increase your control over those
trafficking victims this bill is a
traffickers charter modern day slavery
the previous British prime minister
boxri promised to end it and I respect
the work that she did but this one the
current one wants to enable it how low
have the Tory party Fallen
even worse for children this bill allows
the Home Secretary to lock them up
indefinitely safeguards all removed it
allows her to remove unaccompanied
children without even considering the
details of their case and whether they
have fled from persecution and once they
hit 18 it requires her to remove them
even if the only family or support that
they have in the entire world are here
in the UK and even if they have been
exploited and abused by criminal gangs
and it denies them any protection from
Modern slavery it makes them forever
illegal in the UK
does a shadow of Home Secretary show may
concern but it wasn't three legislative
consultation with the children's
commissioner before this legislation was
brought forward yeah why do you think it
was the case yeah
my honorable friend is right and the
children's commissioner I think is
appalled by some of the measures in this
bill and the lack of consultation as
well
because remember those hundreds of
children missing from Asylum hotels
the ones you've almost certainly been
picked up by The Smuggler and
trafficking gangs this bill makes it
even harder to get those kids back makes
it even easier for those gangs to
increase their control it means no
Sanctuary or just temporary support at
most for Eritrean girls who will most
likely have been raped or exploited or
for the 12 and 13 year olds that I met a
few years ago brought here by gangs from
Afghanistan
or for children who endure what happened
to Mo Farah yeah they would be denied
Refuge
they would be denied citizenship
they would be locked up
and threatened with return
Home Secretary may not want to admit it
but that is what this bill does it
denies citizenship forever for people
like Mo Farah
the Tory party once voted to introduce
safeguards on the Detention of children
and they were right to do so the Tory
party once voted to introduce the modern
slavery Bill and they were right to do
so but what has happened to them now how
low have they fallen and how far down
are they trying to drag our proud
country because that is what this is
it's an attempt to drag our whole
country down they know this bill won't
work to stop both Crossings or to stop
the gangs they know it won't clear the
backlog they know it will make the chaos
worse they know it will stop children
and trafficking gangs getting help and
play into the hands of criminal gangs
and they know it will undermine our
reputation in the eyes of the world as a
country that believes in the rule of law
but they don't care
because this is about political gains
this is about a lame prime minister
making promises that he has no intention
of keeping all he wants is a dividing
line all he wants is to pick a fight and
all he wants is someone else to blame
and he doesn't care if our International
reputation or some very vulnerable
people pay the price a give way to The
Honorable member I'm grateful to the
wife of a lady for giving way will she
accept that there will be many on this
side of the house me included who will
vote for this bill this evening
but with a clear understanding that we
wish to see amendments to it as it
progresses through Parliament
in particular the nation in in
particular in particular relation in
particular relation
to women who are trafficked and to
children so our votes are being given on
good faith tonight in the expectation
and the expectation
in the expectation that the bill could
be amended does she accept that
celebrity speaker I do recognize that
there are members on the benches
opposite who are deeply troubled by many
of the measures in this bill I do
recognize that
and I think that does reflect
quite how far I believe the conservative
party has fallen and I am sorry that
that has happened
this is I think
about an area we should be able to build
consensus not division
in past areas there has been consensus
for example on support for Syrian
refugees go back Generations on support
for the Kinder transport there has been
that support in place we've also had
past consensus about the kind of
practical sensible measures around
border security as well I believe it
should be possible to build that
consensus and we would work with the
government to do that but that is not
what we are getting from the
conservative party the conservative
government the prime minister and the
Home Secretary instead we have got home
secretary who's quite happy to ramp up
the rhetoric rather than ever build a
calm consensus around a practical plan
that sorts things out and how desperate
does it become if what you're doing is
ramping up hostility and hatred towards
the victims of trafficking and slavery
that is not leadership Britain is better
than this Mr Deputy speaker labor will
vote for Action to stop the gangs and to
prevent these dangerous boat process
things we'll vote for a new cross-border
police unit for fast-track decisions and
returns to clear the backlog and end
Hotel use for new agreements with France
and other countries on returns on family
reunion on reforming resettlement we
will vote for Action that rebuilds
border security and restores a properly
functioning credible Asylum and Refugee
system that is properly controlled but
we will not vote for more chaos we will
not vote for a traffickers charter that
lets criminal gangs off the hook that
fails to tackle dangerous Boat Crossings
and that locks up children and leaves
some of the most vulnerable people
undermined we won't vote for this bill
tonight
[Applause]
the original question was that the bill
be now ready second time since when an
amendment has been proposed as on the
order paper the question is that the
amendment be made
Theresa May will get six minutes then
we're on to the SNP spokesperson and
then there will be two others at six
minutes it will drop immediately to
three minutes in order that we can get
as many people in Theresa May you Mr
Deputy speaker having been home
secretary for six years I understand the
pressures to deal with illegal migration
in my day people were getting into facts
of lorries and the backs of cars of
British tourists returning across the
border at Calais I did a deal with the
French the numbers went down I have to
say I suspect it is partly because of
the success of that policy that we now
see people coming in small boats
I welcome the new deal with it's been
done with France because it will have an
impact but what should be clear from
this is that whenever you close a route
for migrants and whenever you close a
route the migrants and the people
Smugglers find another way and anybody
who thinks that this bill will deal with
the issue of illegal migration once and
for raw is wrong not least because a
significant number if not the majority
of people who are here illegally don't
come on small boats they come legally
and overstay their visas
as well as working to reduce illegal
migration is has been mentioned
introduced the modern slavery act that
was World leading legislation it dealt
with traffickers and people who were
being enslaved here in the United
Kingdom British citizens but it was
never Just a Bill about slavery in the
UK it as we saw with the prosecution of
a British woman under that act for
trafficking women from Nigeria to
Germany and I must say there has been
some loose talk about people smuggling
and human trafficking and losing the two
terms in the same breath as if they're
the same they're not they're two
separate crimes someone paying their own
money to be smuggled across the border
is not a victim of human trafficking
which includes coercion exploitation
nobody wants to see our world-leading
legislation being abused but the
government has to set out the clear
evidence if they are saying there is a
link between that and the small votes
and so far I have not seen that evidence
and remember nearly 90 of modern slavery
claims are found to be valid now that
doesn't include recent applications but
I think that figure should give cause
for concern
I'm concerned that the government has
acted on Albania and the nationality and
borders act neither has been in place
long enough to be able to assess their
impact I don't expect government to
introduce legislation to supersede
legislation recently made the impact of
which is not yet known
but beyond those issues I have three
main concerns with the bill the first is
the blanket dismissal of anyone who is
facing persecution and finds their way
to the UK but illegally
examples have been given by the young
woman fleeing persecution in Iran for
example would have the door to the UK
shut in her face the UK has always
welcomed those who are fleeing
persecution regardless of whether they
come through a safe and legal route by
definition someone fleeing for their
life will more often than not be unable
to access a legal route I don't think
it's enough to say we will meet our
requirements by sending people to claim
asylum in Rwanda
and this matters because of the
reputation of the UK on the world stage
and that matters because the UK's
ability to play a role internationally
is based on our reputation not because
we are British but because of what we
stand for and what we do
my second concern relates to the
implications for modern slavery I'm
grateful to the fact the fact that
number 10 has offered to discuss this
with me and I hope we can find some
resolution but as it currently stands we
are shutting the door on victims while
being trafficked into slavery here in
the UK if they come here illegally they
would not be supported to escape their
slavery and the home office itself
recognizes the damage this bill will do
in the explanatory notes they make the
point about the Clauses 21-28 on public
order disqualification these Provisions
are subject to a sun setting mechanism
so that they can be suspended should the
current exceptional illegal migration
situation no longer apply in other words
we know this isn't ideal but we've got
lots of people coming illegally we've
got to do something so the victims of
modern slavery if you like will be
collateral damage
I welcome the acknowledgment this part
of the bill could be reversed but it
could also then be reinstated
the home office knows this bill means
genuine victims of modern slavery will
be denied support
and my third concern is one that has
been echoed by other former home
secretaries of both major parties namely
will it work
for this policy to work it seems a
number of things have to fall into place
there has to be no possibility of
successful legal challenge it requires
the provision of extra detention
capabilities and the assurance that no
one will be able to abscond it requires
the legal individual legal cases
relating to deportation to Rwanda to be
resolved in the government's favor
reminded a process more than the fewer
than 250 Asylum claims they process
currently every year
that to provide extra accommodation and
accept the many thousands of extra
people and agreements on returns with
countries around the world and then the
ability to ensure those returns
dealing with immigration is never easy
there's never a simple answer to any
problem and it's never possible to take
one's Eye Off the Ball it requires
constant vigilance but also
International cooperation the government
I will give way I'm very grateful I'm
grateful to write on my electoral friend
for raising the case of human
trafficking I conducted the court of
appeal case uh but with regard to an uh
and due to lenient Center so we got that
sentence increased it is vitally
important that everybody understands the
difference between trafficking and being
people between trafficking people
smuggling if we don't get basic terms
like that right how on Earth are we
going to get this policy right can I say
to my right honorable friend I'm very
grateful for the work that he did and
for his recognition of the difference
between people smuggling and human
trafficking it is imperative that we use
careful language in relation to these
issues and that we recognize that what
this bill does is remove support from
the victims of trafficking and modern
slavery the government is working hard I
know to find a problem to find a
solution to the problem with small boats
but I think there are a number of
reasons which shed doubt on the approach
being taken I look forward to working
them went on on with them on this issue
to ensure we can deal with the problem
of dangerous sea Crossings can save
people's lives but at the same time
maintain our reputation as a country
that welcomes people fleeing persecution
and crucially maintain our reputation as
a world leader in dealing with modern
slavery
[Applause]
thank you very much Mr Deputy speaker
Refugee ban bill is nothing but an
important dog whistle and me and my
colleagues and I on the SNP benches do
not support it but we do support is the
refugee convention the European
convention and human rights and human
rights act and we support our
functioning and fair immigration system
which is a million miles away from what
we have just now
there is a mosaic based on a Norman
Rockwell painting that hangs in the
United Nations it features the faces of
people of all backgrounds and is
inscribed with the caption due unto
others as you would have them do unto
you it's called the Golden Rule
Britain feels completely and utterly in
the application of this golden room I
asked members here and everybody
listening to close their eyes for a
minute
Place yourself in the shoes of a person
so terrified that they must flee for
their lives a person of Faith perhaps
who finds themselves in the wrong
country a woman activist facing
repression in Iran a mother desperate to
protect her daughter from FGM a boy
hiding after seeing his family murdered
facing forcible recruitment or death
you leave the world you know travel
across mountain and desert in trucks in
cars on feet bleeding and sore you face
setbacks abuse and exploitation you use
every resource you have finally you step
on a flimsy dinner
because the only way to cross the
English Channel to the uncle that you
know who still lives in the UK he's the
only family member you have who is still
alive there is no other route
and when you arrive so close to him what
happens
you're seized you're imprisoned you're
not permitted access to a lawyer you're
not given the chance to plead your case
you're whisked away from the sanctuary
which is so close you can almost touch
it for this Tory government is prepared
to ignore the plight of this persecuted
person of Faith these women this child
and so many others in circumstances like
them they will have no chance of ever
finding sanctuary in the UK the door is
closed permanently due unto others as
you would have them do unto you
this spell is being rushed through with
no proper impact assessment on the back
of legislation that is barely even in
place barely even cold from last year
and Mr Speaker Mr Deputy speaker the
Home Secretary declares clearly in the
front page of this legislation I am
unable to make a statement that in my
view the provisions of the illegal
migration Bill are compatible with
convention rights but the government
nevertheless Wishes the house to proceed
with the bill it is the illegal
migration Bill not legal not just
incompatible with the Human Rights Act
1998 which gives effect to the European
convention on human rights now echr as
much as they would have you believe it
it's not a bureaucratic creation but a
system championed by Winston Churchill
who one of its key drafters it was David
Maxwell if a former conservative Home
Secretary and one of the prosecutors at
Nuremberg it is bang on form for a UK
government which has previously sought
to break international law and specific
in limited ways but this bill is even
more Danger than that it undermines the
fundamental International obligations
which their predecessors established
under the 1951 Refugee convention
following the horrors of the second
World War
unhcr have condemned the bill stating
the legislation of past would amount to
an asylum ban extinguishing the right to
seek Refugee protection in the United
Kingdom for those who arrive irregularly
no matter how genuine and compelling
their claim may be and with no
consideration other individual
circumstances
I'm sure we've all been inundated with
briefings and from contacts from
constituents and organizations on this
despicable piece of legislation and I
will try my best to try and reflect the
many concerns which have been raised
with me but overwhelmingly I would like
to thank the constituents of Glasgow
Central who has one would expect from
the city that gave us the Glasgow girls
the Glasgow gurneys and the neighborhood
solidarity of Kenmore streets they are
resolutely opposed to this
Mr Deputy speaker this bill is unfair in
many respects but particularly so by
having retrospective effect Parliament
has only just begun the process of
debating this hideous legislation yet it
will impact people who arrive from the
7th of March when the bill was
introduced people cannot yet know for
certain what this bill will look like
yet they are already severely impacted
by it
the provisions which affect children in
this bill are amongst the more
disturbling parts of a very bad piece of
legislation Clause 32 states that the
Secretary of State may make arrangements
for the removal of a person from the
United Kingdom at a time when the person
is an unaccompanied child an
unaccompanied child do unto others as
they would have them do to You
children's commissioner Bruce Adamson
has stated his clear opposition to this
bill the UK is required to ensure that
children seeking Refugee status receive
appropriate protection and humanitarian
assistance under article 22 of the UN
convention on the rights of the child
you're here uncrc also requires the UK
to ensure that children are protected
from exploitation and abuse and afforded
support for recovery this bill violates
those obligations and many others it's
an argument would place the UK and clear
Beach of its International obligations
under a range of Human Rights treaties
says Bruce Adamson
this bill reaches into Scotland Wales in
Northern Ireland too in sections 15 to
18 seizing powers to undermine clear
protections that we have established in
our default institutions to protect all
Scotland's wines
Bernardus have rightly queried by the
Bell seats together the home office the
pair to accommodate children when there
are currently hundreds of children
missing from home office accommodation
and on the county forums they also want
to know whether an unaccompanied child
who's arrived in the UK irregularly will
be routingly placed into specialist
Foster Care As a matter of policy or be
eligible to for adoption they ask
whether if two siblings are trafficked
into the UK where one is 12 years old
and what the other is 18 will the bit
will essentially mean that both will be
detained and removed from the UK and
denied any protection
and if an accompanied child is
trafficked into the UK and is granted
protection through the national referral
mechanism and a family member who they
may not even have ever met arrives in
the UK a regularly at a later Point does
that then disqualify the child's modern
slavery protection this whole area is
deeply problematic and even more so as
the bill allows for removal as soon as
an unaccompanied child does turn 18.
as is clear the current and
admissibility rules from the nationality
and Border act do not work expanding an
admissibility creates a situation where
there is no right of appeal do not pass
go do not collect omega-8 pounds a week
in an overhead crowded Hotel go directly
to immigration jail and wait and move
removal there are some very tight
grounds for a technical appeal but the
potential for people being removed to
places where they will be at risk of
persecution is real
I would love to know what the Home
Secretary how the Home Secretary will
know the details of a person's claim if
it is not going to be fully assessed the
bill talks in Clause 6 about the
potential for a person to be at risk of
persecution for their sex their language
their race their religion their
nationality their membership of a social
or other group political opinion or any
other attribute or circumstance the Home
Secretary is appropriate yet if there's
no application declaration no assessment
or ability to seek legal advice and a
presumption of inadmissibility how will
she know
the former member of parliament the
former prime minister the member from
eating head who I often disagreed with
when she was Home Secretary and prime
minister is correct to be concerned
about many of the mechanisms in this
film it is beyond all logic and reason
that the Home Secretary should rip up
these important protections the
legislation also overrides the human
trafficking and exploitation Scotland
act 2015 against our will
ilper has said that Clause is 21 to 28
concerning what is theory and
trafficking clearly breached the UK's
obligations to victims of trafficking
under Article 4 of the echr and the
European convention on action against
trafficking these Provisions will
deprive victims of their right to
recovery expose them to re-exploitation
and facilitate the work of trafficking
gangs and I have met people that have
been supported through the Tara
organization in Glasgow I have seen how
damaged some of those people have been
and it breaks my heart to think that
this government would lock them up and
give them no support whatsoever
Amnesty International this bill creates
a charter for human exploitation placing
many of the most marginalized people
firmly in the hands of human traffickers
modern day slavers and other abusers it
widens the power imbalance between those
being abused and their abusers and it
makes it far far more difficult for
those people ever to Break Free the risk
of now doing so is that they're removed
from the UK permanently and their
abusers you can bet will use that threat
over them why on Earth with the Home
Secretary consider this a sensible idea
the Clauses on entry into and settlement
in the United Kingdom are brutal there
is no entry there is no chance of
settlement permanently and forever a
person can never enter the UK if they
met one if they once met the four
conditions the Home Secretary is setting
for legal entry or indeed if they are a
family member of that person so talk
about holding the child respond
accountable for the sins of the Father
the supplies I understand even if the
child was born here and this will surely
also have the wider impact of hitting
people well into the future who may wish
to come as visit as tourists a worker to
study they may have no knowledge of that
previous Banning order so why would the
Home Secretary wish to deny that
opportunity what message does she think
that sends out into the world this
pulling up of the drawbridge
close 51 outlings the capping of safe
and legal Roots now these proposed roots
are to be brought forward in regulations
and the Home Secretary is dangling a
carrot that this may happen perhaps at
some point in the future maybe perhaps
in the fullness of time when
parliamentary time allows I write
Mr Deputy speaker we need those safe and
legal Roots now they are part of the
solution to the small boat crisis
because people coming by that route are
doing that because there is no other
option people cannot claim for Asylum
for a bird they literally need to place
their feet on this island it is not by
some coincidence that there are no
ukrainians paying people to come by
dinghy because they can get on a plane
from Poland and fly to the UK without
the risk of being returned there it is
cheaper it is safer it is Humane
the Glasgow solicitors foreign Makai
mentioned that they were dealing with
some people from El Salvador for which
there was a Visa waiver scheme so those
people could get here safely the home
office shut it down
and Afghans Afghans do not have the
privilege of getting on a plane and
coming here just 22 people have been
resettled in the UK including eight
children under the Afghan citizens
resettlement scheme via referral from
unhcr pathway two is the only route open
for us resettlement for Afghans who are
not already in the UK
I will give away
I'm grateful to Don real lady she's
mentioning safe and legal Roots I'm very
keen that we need greater definition on
the bill I'm also Keen that we need some
greater safeguards for vulnerable
children but she has exclusively as with
the shadow Home Secretary focused on
extreme cases who may fall foul and
that's why we need those additional
criteria added on the bill she has not
just as the shadow Home Secretary made
no mention of people who come across the
channel who actually are not genuine
Asylum Seekers who have no genuine
credible claim to come to United Kingdom
she seems to assume that everybody
coming across the channel is one of
those vulnerable people they're not so
what would you do about what would you
do about those people genuinely abusing
our hospitality
[Music]
and I know that the vast majority of
people that do come over are accepted as
Asylum get their Refugee status and he
also knows he also knows that without
those safe and legal Roots the question
that he asked to the Home Secretary at
the home Affairs select committee
remains unanswered and under this bill
the Home Secretary isn't going to even
ask
to find out whether or not these people
are genuine everybody is deemed to be
some kind of food
returning to the Afghan scheme which
does not work I've spoken Friday to my
constituent Zakir who's been trying to
reunite with her sister since the fall
of Afghanistan her sister has had the
Taliban enter her home and beat her
she has played by the rules as the Home
Secretary set out it says that people
should she's made an expression of
interest and still nothing and if the
Home Secretary was in this woman's shoes
would she really sit tight in
Afghanistan and wait for the Taliban to
murder her because that is what happens
to women in Afghanistan do unto others
as you would have them do unto you
capping these roots roots that don't
even exist right now would suggest that
you if you're the X plus one person well
that's just too bad for you it's not
based and neat a few years ago I was
made aware that the visitor Visa scheme
for Iranians was essentially being run
as a lottery with names being run for
Lucky winners well this government
couldn't run a raffle and I don't trust
them to establish this scheme in a
timely or Fair Manner and if you'd like
to give me some experience from his
constituents of how difficult it is to
come from Afghanistan I'd be glad to
hear it
lady way she's speaking of safe
and legal Roots good mat globally there
are over 100 million displaced people I
wonder if she could be kind enough to
confirm how many of these people an
independent Scotland would take what tax
Rises
and how many additional people you're
willing to accept in central Glasgow
[Applause]
If he if he knew anything at all he
would know that my Glasgow Central
constituency has the highest immigration
caseload of any constituency in Scotland
and we are proud We are proud that that
is so
I would like to know how many are
actually being housed in this
constituency and I would say as well
that Scotland has taken the highest
proportion of a Ukrainian refugees we
have taken the highest proportion
obsidian refugees we have a protest
today in Scotland and we will do much
much better than this pathetic excuse
for the government over here
turning I will give away in just one
second I was going to turn to the
practicalities
this bill because there is no proof that
this bill will work any more than the
nationality and borders act worked any
more than the hospital the hostile
environment worked because we were told
that those things at that time were the
solution to the problems that we have
they have evidently failed because
they're back here legislating again
there is no return agreement with the EU
or anywhere else ironically for the
brexiteers and the benches opposite
leaving the EU has made this much much
more difficult the bill lists EA
countries and Albania a deal doesn't
exist and there are already countries as
we know around the world where the UK
government will not return people and
others but there are no flights and no
means of return what this bill does do
is create an underclass of people stuck
in an immigration limbo indefinitely
the bill will detain everybody arriving
in a small boat for 28 days the UK's
current detention capacity is 2286 bids
the number of people crossing in small
boats last year was 45
755 and for context this year the prison
population in England and Wales in 2022
was just over 81 000 people so we're in
Earth We're on Earth is actually suggest
that the number of people she wishes to
detain are kept as well as those that
are deemed an admissible but
unreturnable will there be in facilities
like manston with children sleeping in
the floor and dilapidated in crumbling
facilities like Napier Barracks were
covered and scabies were Rife and hotels
which is lining in the pockets of
companies like Circle and mirrors but
costing the government a fortune and
putting vulnerable Asylum Seekers at
risk such as those being housed in
Erskine in Scotland where they are being
targeted by far right groups or perhaps
I will
is potentially allowed to such hotel in
the UK and another hotel in Memphis
unlike the honor member for for
Gloucester there's government and the
bench shops that are said that Scotland
doesn't play its part that's clearly not
the case means meanwhile Patrick
patriotic alternative the neo-fascist
group are blaming the SNP for these
hotels being used in the hospitals
leading to security effects against my
staff which excuse me any member's
opposite who support anything patriotic
alternative have said should be
thoroughly thoroughly ashamed of
themselves
[Music]
I absolutely agree with the sentiments
that he shares and we should all be very
worried about the rise of these groups
and how they are being fed by the
rhetoric of leaders uh and MPS across
the way
Perhaps Perhaps They're laughing over
there at this suggestion it is
terrifying and it's scary and people
will get hurt they should know much
better perhaps if if they can't fit them
into more Asylum hotels or shabby
Barracks uh perhaps Home Secretary will
place those who have survived war and
persecution on the streets and just let
them wander the streets because they
will not be allowed to do anything else
the Home Secretary seems to envisage
this as some kind of deterrent but she
feels completely to recognize the
reasons why people flee the ties of
family and English language that people
have and as the Afghan interpreters have
said to me we are here because you were
there
as inverse Solomon CEO of the refugee
Council has also said the plans won't
stop the crossings but we'll simply
leave traumatized people locked up in a
state of misery being treated as
criminals and suspected terrorists
without a fear hearing on our soil and
all of this Mr Deputy speaker comes at a
financial cost as well as a humanitarian
and you would imagine the conservatives
would at least care about that around 6
million pounds per day on hotels
including one of my constituents who
contacted me to do who's been in a BNB
for 20 months waiting on a decision from
the home office
exacerbated all the way by home office
and competence which I see week in week
out at my surgeries 12.7 million to
compensate the 572 people the home
office detained unlawfully last year 120
million pounds at least on the field
Rwanda deal 480 million pounds to France
over on top over the next three years on
top of the 250 million already given
since 2014 and the refugee Council
estimated it will cost in the region of
980 million to detain people under the
scheme proposed in the bill today it's
chucking good money after bad policy and
it is sickening that it costs so much to
treat our human our fellow human beings
so badly
my constituent Patricia said put it to
me so clearly on Saturday she said I am
not Asylum I have a name I'm a human
being and every human being has a right
you don't need to be an exceptional
athlete like mufara chief executive of
the Scottish Refugee Council like some
years as I a counselor like Rosa Sally
and Abdul bastani or even an
oscar-winning actor like
refugees are entitled to read to the
right to lead an unremarkable life in
peace and safety to get an education and
to provide for their family it is not
asking too much it is the least anyone
could expect do unto others as you would
have them do unto you
Mr Speaker the SNP wholeheartedly and
unequivocally condemned this cruel
shoddy Tory Bill we urge the government
to scrap it and to focus instead and
tackling the Asylum backlog which leaves
so many of our constituents in a costly
and damaging limbo lift the bound let
refugees work and contribute as they so
wish to do
and it's been telling Mr Deputy speaker
the labor party have been so weak in
their opposition to be that to this bill
as to be played off the park by Football
pundits commentators and actresses like
Kate Blanchett
my credit to the principal stance taken
by Gary lineker and his colleagues
suddenly Ken muiring the BBC and I bet
if he tweeted in favor of the bill he
would not Feast the red card worthy
simulation of outrage from the Tory
benches because it seems if you're a
Tory donor and you can run the BBC but
if you oppose this pathetic excuse for
the government they don't want you to
work there
Mr Speaker Scott Mr Deputy speaker
Scotland stands against this bill we
would not have such cruel possessions in
an independent Scotland we wish to be
known for our kindness and our
hospitality and our compassion not our
heart-heartedness and our cruelty we
would do unto others as they would have
them do unto us say it loud and say it
clear refugees are welcome
thank you
six minute limit on the next two then
three minutes so Robert Buckland thank
you Mr Deputy speaker
um as
a debate I frankly get
pressed what we hear is artificial
juxtapositions between uh either a
position of an open door policy letting
everybody into this country or a
suggestion that on this side of the
house we are cruel we are callous and
that we don't care about people now can
I deal with that second Point utterly
utterly wrong as Justice secretary I
work very hard to make sure that the
nationality and borders bill was able to
make its way through this house and I
yield to nobody in my determination to
make sure that those who seek to exploit
others and to profit on the back of
people who are vulnerable and who
clearly are not Asylum Seekers for their
economic migrants must be dealt with and
I think this party should make no
apology for wanting to make sure that
that issue is a address fair and square
that's what the people who put us here
expect us to do that's what our
constituents want us to do what our
constituents are fed up of uh Mr Deputy
speaker is the seeming inability of the
system to enforce the laws that we pass
in this place to get on with the job of
lawful deportation to make sure that
people who don't overstay their who
overstay their visas don't do not stay
here because that's my right on my
friend
um the uh honorable the member for
maidenhead said that is the main cause
of a lawful migration the overstaying of
visas now that's not to minimize the
small boats issue but it is to put it
into context the small boats crisis as
we describe it is actually the product
of a successful approach that we took
when it came to the control of lorries
and the appalling incidents that we saw
where many people lost their lives as a
result of Suffocation and other Horrors
now as a result of that we pl we plugged
that loophole I'm pretty sure that if we
succeed in plugging this loophole
another one will emerge from all the
evidence I know from Asylum Seekers I
speak to in my constituents and I do so
regularly uh Mr Deputy speaker this is a
price driven Market it is simply cheaper
to come on small boats than it is to
come here by other means at the moment a
hearing lies I think the source of the
problem the government is seeking once
again to use law where I believe
primarily it is operations that matter
more than anything and in particular the
ability of this country to strike uh
sensible agreements with not just France
but other members of the European Union
as well in order to have a managed
system of return a quota system frankly
that would make eminent sense in dealing
with what is an international problem we
came together on Ukraine why on Earth
can't we come together on this and that
would make sense of clause 51 Mr Deputy
speaker the governments wish to have a
debate in this house on a cap or quote I
think that's a sensible measure but it
will only work if we extend safe routes
of passage in a controlled and measured
way we've got to do more on safe and
legal routes in fact doing that would
strengthen the government's case against
those people who are choosing small boat
it's plain as a pike staff to me but
that must happen in 10 them with this
legislation no good passing this
legislation unless we do those other
operational things and uh just to uh in
perhaps not second reading tradition but
deal with a particular Clause of the
bill Clause 3 about the Detention of
children which I have great concern
about I know it's a it's a power Mr
Deputy speaker it's not a duty but when
powers are put into build it's usually
because the policy makers haven't
actually decided what to do and whether
to use them and it's a it's a holding
mechanism in order for the government to
make a decision well are my strong
suggestion to them when we come to
amendment is to is to ditch that clause
and to look very carefully at the way in
which we deal with unaccompanied
children families and women because
there's nothing worse would Mr Deputy
speaker than ineffective
authoritarianism and that is the danger
of Provisions like that and I can wait
with my right honorable friend agree
that uh in looking at Clause 3 as you
said if the government were to look at
Clause 29 4B
particularly the phrase compelling
evidence
some if the government were to bring
criteria forward which defined
compelling evidence that might reassure
a number of us on this side that it will
prevent the illegal sex trafficking of
young women
within within the close of the bill not
being allowed to seek provision and
protection under the sex at modern
slavery bill I think my my honorable
friend is right it's going to be vitally
important that there is clear guidance I
mean we've been here before I mean when
it comes to modern day slavery there has
been a question about the interpretation
of guidance I know that is a Vex
question for the government I know that
whether my right honorable offender
minister of state of sits on the bench
is assiduous in these matters I know
we'll want to get it right but we have
an opportunity in committee and that
report to do so because as presented
this bill is not yet in the state that
it needs to be if it is in my view to
have the effect that I think the
government wanted to have and can I say
about uh the interaction between this
bill and the European convention or
human rights I do hope Mr Deputy speaker
that this bill isn't being used as some
sort of battering ram to make a wider
political point about the validity of
the European convention because I can
tell you I can tell you the European
Venture is not the problem in this case
and those who think it is a setting up a
massive aunt's salary when it comes to
actually what the issues are because
whether we're in the convention or not
domestic law and our rule of law
tradition and the procedures that we
have under various immigration acts some
of which I've been involved with passing
in this house will inevitably impose
principles of natural Justice upon uh
any process and the idea that through a
blanket approach that somehow we
engineer a battle with a court a battle
with the European convention is I think
misconceived and it is it is a journey
upon which I would urge the government
not to involve no need to talk about
withdrawal from a convention that
British conservatives wrote what we need
to focus upon relentlessly Mr Deputy
speaker in dealing in a grow grown up
and mature way with a serious situation
such as this is to make sure that
internationally our reputation as
reasonable actors as people with whom
other countries can do business as a
place where people will want to invest
is enhanced by the approach that we take
to these issues and that is why the tone
of this debate is so important and I'm
concerned Mr Deputy speaker that in some
of the utterances I hear from my party
that tone is not appropriate we have to
do better we have to rise to the level
of events we have to get it right yeah
yeah yeah yeah
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and just
following up on that point on the issue
of tone despite the very strong views
held on this piece of legislation both
in this house and outside by actors
Football commentators and archbishops I
do believe there is a consensus that we
all want to stop people crossing the
channel in unsafe small boats risking
their lives in some of the busiest
shipping lanes in the world and this
government's Flagship immigration Bill
underpins one of the prime minister's
five priorities to the British people
and it's so important that's why I asked
the leader of the house if the home
Affairs select committee could carry out
pre-legislative scrutiny to test the
robustness and the evidence supporting
this bill sadly that's not been possible
and it's also disappointing that we
haven't had an impact assessment and
equality impact assessment or a child
rights impact assessment accompanying
the publication of the bill now I also
hope there's consensus across the house
that the UK should of course do its bit
to support those fleeing persecution and
torture sharing this responsibility with
our International partners and we do
need to put this into context not every
displaced person in the World wants to
come to the United Kingdom that's right
and we are not facing an invasion we
know that countries such as turkey take
the Lion's Share of refugees and nearly
70 percent of refugees mainly end up
staying in the region they come from so
what exactly should the government be
doing about small boats Last Summer the
home Affairs select committee published
our report into Channel Crossings we
made the important point in our report
there is no one magic bullet that will
solve this problem and as I made clear
last week the Home Secretary is right
that our Asylum system is broken but it
is not the migrants crossing the channel
who broke it poor resourcing Antiquated
I.T systems high-step turnover of too
few staff has resulted in this backlog
of 160 000 cases tackling the backlog
has to be the most important priority
for the home office and another key
message from our report was the need for
detailed evidence-driven fully costed
and fully tested policy to tackle this
problem rather than simple headline
grabbing announcements such as Rwanda
for which there is still no body of
evidence on the potential deterrent
effect other recommendations included
the importance of establishing a returns
agreement with the EU extending family
reunion and creating safe and legal
routes we all know that people may
travel without papers using irregular
methods but have a solid case for
seeking Asylum which needs to be
considered under our International
obligations this bill currently would
deny that opportunity positively at the
end of last week we saw further
agreement with the French on tackling
small boats albeit we still need that
returns agreement with the EU and whilst
it's encouraging that the government is
improving its relationship with the EU
We Now find the government stress
testing or International obligations and
potentially breaking international law
turning to the specifics of the bill
first of all the proposals in this bill
present a huge logistical challenge for
a department not known for good project
management for being on the front foot
it has three essential pillars detention
deportation and deterrence each race
serious and fundamental practical issues
that we need clear answers to understand
how the bill will work the institute for
government have very helpfully
summarized the key questions number one
does the bill adhere to the UK's
International obligations two how does
the bill change existing policy on
inadmissible claims three what can the
government where can the government send
Asylum Seekers deemed inadmissible four
what does the Home Secretary consider to
be a reasonable Prospect of removal five
what will happen to people the
government cannot remove to another
country six how will the government
accommodate people it is detained and
how will it pay pay to do so and
seventhly will it deter people from
crossing the channel in small boats I
have very many concerns particularly on
the provisions relating to unaccompanied
children Children and Families being
detained and victims of trafficking and
modern slavery the Salvation Army have
stated in their briefing on the bill
that modern slavery is not an
immigration issue it's a safeguarding
issue the men women and children
trafficked against their will to the UK
and enslaved should not be punished for
being victims but this is what the
immigration migration the illegal
migration bill will do finally looking
at deterrence
on the select committee's visit to
France earlier this year we heard
evidence that people who've arrived in
northern France having traveled
thousands of miles in some cases will
not be put off when they can see the
British Coastline from the French Beach
and have little or no knowledge of what
the home office policy or British law is
that we therefore need to fully
understand how this plan for detention
deportation and deterrence will work in
Practical terms I'm concerned that the
bill potentially leaves the home office
in illegal Quagmire with up to tens of
thousands of people detained for a
period and then bailed into a permanent
state of limbo unable to be removed
unable to have their Asylum claims
process and unable to reunite with
families and there is nothing
specifically in this bill about tackling
criminal gangs people Smugglers and
traffickers to just to conclude we all
want action on small boats but what we
want is effective action that will deal
with the problem
Sir John Hayes countries mean more than
their borders National character shared
Heritage and institutions that give that
history life matter but borders matter
too but they are what Mark the territory
which defines citizenship with its
implicit entitlements and
responsibilities opportunities and Duty
and the plain fact is that our Kingdom's
borders are being breached day after day
with impunity
since 2018 some 85 000 people have
entered Britain illegally 45 000 of them
in 2022 74 are man under 40 a hundred
percent have traveled through safe
countries to get here where they fail to
claim Asylum accommodating them is
costing the British taxpayer costing the
British pact there every single day six
million pounds it can not go on of
course Britain should provide a safe
haven for people in need in genuine need
but it is a deceit to pretend the Asylum
system is not being gained and the
British people take them for a ride
economic migrants with no legal right to
be here enabled by fat cat law firms
who've grown rich on the proceeds
I ended up better by militant interest
groups who are determined to convert the
word of the people and cheered on
cheered on by vacuous self-indulgent
celebrities leaving millionaire
Lifestyles it may be uncomfortable it
may be uncomfortable for the Bourgeois
liberal establishment the polls show the
British people the British people want
tough action on illegal immigration
indeed polling last week's show the
people support the principles of this
bill Mr Speaker David Israeli said
Justice is truth in action today the
government is giving voice to the true
wish of the British people to restore
Justice to our immigration and Asylum
system it is not extreme to want to Cap
all kinds of immigration it is not in
moderate to deport illegal immigrants it
is not unreasonable it is not
unreasonable to give the government the
tools they need to do just that
it is time to take back control of our
borders it is time to stop the votes
to George Howarth
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I have to
say the honorable member for South
Holland in the deepings makes a very
unlikely class Warrior
um I'd also perhaps like to say that
um
the my honorable great honorable friend
and a member for normanson pontefract
and Castleford gave her usual forensic
analysis of the situation and I'm very
grateful to her for doing that and also
the I I want to agree with the Home
Secretary of one thing
and that is when she said we should
choose our words carefully it's just a
Pity she didn't do so herself
um Mr Speaker the reason I wanted to
speak in this debate is that because as
you're aware there is a hotel in
knowsley with 180 plus Asylum Seekers
I won't talk about that in detail
because I had an urgent question on it a
few weeks ago but what I will say is
since then
the situation is deteriorated to the
extent that some of the refugees have
been verbally abused in the street and
others have been assaulted
and they have fled because the countries
they come from were unsafe only to find
themselves in an unsafe position in this
country and I think we should all be
ashamed not just happening in those that
it's happening all over the country
about that I just want to conclude
um
Mr Deputy speaker by saying something
about why it is
we've got this bill before us in this
house my right honorable friend the
shadow Home Secretary convincingly
pointed out the failures in the system
that have led to this
but why are the government themselves
bringing forward a bill for anybody who
knows anything about it knows isn't
going to work that's right and the
answer is with some notable exception as
the right honorable lady from maidenhead
and the uh honorable lady for romsey in
Southampton North to name but two
um
broadly speaking those on the benches
opposite split into two groups the first
group are deluded and actually believe
this is going to work
and the second group are cynical
and don't believe it's going to work but
they're going along with it anyway and I
think Mr Deputy speaker that is a
shameful set of circumstances
at least those who are deluded will wake
up tomorrow morning and think
well we were still right
those who are cynical know they'll have
to wake up tomorrow morning look at
themselves in the mirror and they'll be
ought to be ashamed of themselves but
Walden you Mr Speaker many in this house
want to say that the government is
inciting people's worst instincts on
immigration and I want to say ultimately
and ultimately optimistically that it's
not this bill it's not this Home
Secretary it's not this government that
is causing that feeling in fact it's in
touch with the widespread symptoms of it
from people decent people in
constituencies up and down this country
like mine and we have to heed those
views because the reality is Mr Speaker
in my judgment enough of the fine people
of skegness say accurately that they're
already doing a huge amount they say
that asking them to do even more has
Untold consequences they say in short
that endless numbers cannot be made to
feel welcome if they worry that the town
they are staying in will never be the
same again in part because of it and
when enough people feel this way Mr
Speaker we mainstream moderates in this
house have to act because if we don't we
should know that it is the racism the
extremists of the far left and the far
right that will take our place we've
already seen patriotic alternative March
in skegness if however we act now
there's a chance to stop decent British
people from withdrawing their consent
and that's why the AIMS in tonight's
Bill are not just compassionate they're
the only compassionate option they're
the most compassionate way breaking the
business model of both people Smugglers
and indeed those who buy hotels to sell
back to the home office of profiteers
rates all of that has to end but I want
to end uh Mr Speaker by saying this we
do need to have safe routes from
dangerous countries we do need to have
Provisions for those men and women who
are trafficked and for children who are
taken by what will then be irresponsible
adults to these Shores but we cannot use
those hard cases to pretend that we
can't do better than where we are today
because if we don't compassion will seed
the ground to ignorance and to hatred we
have to act or we will stretch the
license voters give us to act on their
behalf Beyond breaking point in skegness
I'm not exaggerating when I say for some
this is an issue about democracy and the
effectiveness of government itself this
bill isn't about just stopping the boats
it's about stopping that Democratic
tragedy as well and that isn't just one
reason why I will be proud to support it
this evening
and I think the words for member from
Boston and skegness investor remain to
himself and nobody else in this debate
because they don't make any sense or
have any delivery for the people that we
represent the this country is based on
the rule of law
we are in the U.N security Council
we were the writers of the
European Convention of Human Rights
we were the main principals in Geneva
Convention and we also penned the war
crimes legislation that is now in
existence and to accuse people here of
being Lefty lawyers for doing the right
thing to standing up for our rights and
for people in law which is what is in
Shrine we've always worked to the letter
of the law and so we should
the minister the Home Secretary takes no
advice from the bar Council takes no
advice from the Law Society who all say
that there will be a contradiction if
this law is to pass and go forward and
we'll have problems in the court as
they've already previously had so they
don't want to do anything in relation to
that and that's the problem there are no
safe routes for anybody to come through
Afghanistan's been closed Hong Kong's
been closed and you you administered
nods know you try from Afghanistan to
get anywhere out and you'll see what the
issues are and how you deal with that
there are women that have been
trafficked who will have no support from
any of these people that are young
children who will be in Jeopardy who
will have no support under this bill
this bill is against the people this
bill is against the human rights and
civil liberties of people delayed
parties doesn't say there is an open on
free door that is what you say about the
lay party the labor party is here to
look at open and positive immigration
that's what we want to do the Home
Secretary in an open statement said that
she can't be uh she she can't be uh
xenophobic or racist just because of her
color and her Origins well I say to her
of the same color and the same origin
that that is exactly what our politics
are about her politics are about
dividing our society our community based
on that that is what she's doing and
that's what she continues to do I think
the best thing that she can do is to
look at what is right for the people
rather than making political decisions
where she thinks she will win the next
election on that is not the case the
people of the United Kingdom are not so
naive has to take this huge nonsense of
xenophobia and racism from this party to
be put forward what she needs to
understand is she needs to have the milk
of humanity to move forward with these
issues we are all here representing all
of our concessions she does not
understand that I certainly hope for her
sake and forsake all the people that
come through here that we are in
responsible for human and human beings
in terms of our humanity and for moving
forward thank you Mr Speaker so Robert
nail thank you very much Mr Speaker
I Echo the words of my right honor and
learning friend the member for South
Swindon in saying that we need some calm
and seriousness in this debate and that
tone is important even it's sometimes
being lacking in that Spirit can we just
observe that it is not even unlawful or
illegitimate faced with new and novel
developments in the means of a entry
into the United Kingdom to unlawfully to
test the legal position that's what the
bill does no more at this stage it's
legitimate to do that because of course
as somebody who supports the European uh
the uh you know International
conventional refugees we have to
recognize for example that conceived in
1951 at a time when people were smuggled
across borders there was perhaps a
little bit of bribery of local officials
or some altruistic assistance from
people to get over borders that was
beyond a time of organized criminality
exploiting vulnerable people we do have
to reflect the reality of that change in
circumstance and the government is
entitled I think to look at the way in
which that might best be done that's the
case for judicial dialogue in Strasbourg
it's also a case for looking at
renegotiating sodium someone
that said some of us are only able to
support this bill tonight because of the
safeguards that are written into it for
example habeas corpus and others and I
will give way
with my honorable friend except that a
number of us are supporting this bill
tonight on the basis that when we get to
committee and Report stage the
government will confirm the legal basis
in a more detail as to the statement
that this complies with our
International obligations I have great
faith in the uh legal input of the
current attorney general into this bill
and into the advice of senior treasury
council
is right about that and some of us will
be looking to improve their Protections
in relation to children in relation to
families they're in relation to some of
the tests for example the suspensive
serious harm test and also the
compelling circumstances are under
Clause 29 for uh B were it not for
things like that it would be very
difficult to support a bill but they are
in there and we need to build upon those
but I also want to make it clear that
legislation of itself is not a solution
to this left on its own this bill or no
other Bill and any other bill will not
achieve anything the real need is to
operationalize in the situation is to
improve the lamentable performance our
Asylum system and immigration system has
had for a number of years it is
ludicrous that immigration tribunals sit
empty immigration fee paid part-time
judges who were used to Surge capacity
sit unused because the home office is
unable to get the files in order to
present before the tribunal if they
can't get the cases through the system
efficiently and accurately then that
will fail secondly a kind of
isolationist unilateralism will not
solve an international problem either
many of us think that the prime
ministers work on Friday will be every
bit as important as any piece of
legislation in finding a way forward to
get I hope a new agreement with France
on security and then a movement to a
proper returns policy because we need a
returns policy with friendly and safe
countries to make this work I think the
Prime Minister has the seriousness and
the tone to achieve that yeah and
finally we must also make sure that we
work as swiftly to undertake a sensible
approach to the international position
so that we can
make sure that our reputation continues
to be uphill the rule of law matters
domestically and internationally that
does not mean that you turn a blind eye
to organize criminality abusing our
hospitality and that's a real concern to
constituents of mine that's why it's
important that we do move forward but
the idea that any piece of legislation
alone without actually a serious
operational changes and frankly the
resource to go behind them it is uh
misleading
thank you Mr Speaker just as I think
that I cannot be shocked any further by
this government's inhumanity they try to
rush this abhorrent and unlawful Bill
through Parliament human rights and
legal organizations are calling this one
of the most damaging bills put forward
by British government in living memory
this is because the illegal migration
Bill amounts to a refugee ban it
breaches fundamental and internationally
recognized human rights it attacks our
way of life and it attacks our
communities all over the UK
let us be clear persecuting refugees and
anti-migrants game on green does not
benefit the majority of people
the cynical and dangerous use of
scapegoating to divide people by an
unpopular government which has overseen
a horrifying death toll during the
pandemic and continues to inflict
hardship and suffering across the UK
does damage our communities we have
already seen an alarming rise in
violence and intimidation organized by
the far-right against refugees and
Refugee accommodation
but beyond the rhetoric Spin and fake
news Mr Speaker the fundamental point is
that most of the people in small boats
are men women and children escaping
Terror and bloodshed chillingly it is a
truth that the government are obviously
aware of because it knows that the
majority of people arriving in the UK
via boats are granted Asylum and so they
are creating a cruel mechanism to deny
Sanctuary to people they know a
legitimate refugees and are in need and
why are migrants being forced into
risking their lives in the first place
well it's simple for many there are no
safe routes to the UK
in 2022 half of the men women and
children who crossed the channel in
small boats were from Afghanistan
Eritrea Iran Sudan or Syria we know the
reasons why people from such countries
are displaced yet only 22 22 refugees
came to the UK on The Afghan citizens
resettlement scheme how can this be true
and just recently the government
confirmed they does not intend to
introduce any special Visa routes for
people in turkey and Syria who have been
affected by the earthquakes
as the daughter of migrants who faced
violence and persecution from the far
right in East London I am all too
conscious of the consequences of
pandering to racists whether that was
the Bangladeshi Community standing up
and leading the anti-fascist fight back
in Brick Lane following the murder of Al
tabali in 1978 or the Jewish Community
locally who came together in the Battle
of cable Street in 1936 standing up to
oswal mods Mosley
we know in East London we will never let
our communities be divided or targeted
the government should be saving lives
not salvaging their failing political
record we need an approach that
prioritizes people's lives and dignity
we need safe and legal routes to the UK
and we need this Bill thrown out of
parliament
hey Mr Speaker we are we are a rich
country we are the world's fifth largest
economy and we have international
obligations and it is right that we meet
them in 2020 we were the third highest
donor to overseas development in the
area CD in absolute terms and the sixth
highest is a proportion of gross uh
national income we have welcomed
thousands of people to this country from
Syria Afghanistan Ukraine and Hong Kong
and whether it's through the government
and the taxpayer or through people
opening their homes we have seen the
great generosity of the British people
indeed I would say that Gary lineker was
correct today to write as you did on
Twitter that we are a country of
predominantly tolerant welcoming and
generous people yeah but where he I
think he is Rob and I think people on
the opposing argument wrong uh is that
he ignores that that tolerance can be
tested yeah and that generosity while it
is deep it is not Limitless I take a
rather hawkish view on immigration I
think that immigration should be in the
tens of thousands rather than the
hundred thousands but I myself have been
surprised by the depth of feeling of
deadling residence on this issue if I
hold a supermarket surgery or if I knock
on people's doors
what will be raised with me unprompted
if it's not potholes it's the issue of
baits and migrants and I think the the
the depth of that feeling is
understandable given the context Albania
is a top nationality for small boat
arrivals at 25 and
um
and Albania compared with other
countries is perhaps uh not one of the
major countries facing international
issues which for which people are
requesting Asylum and while there are
pool factors including language and
shared history uh The Passage through
multiple safe countries of Asylum
Seekers undermines the idea that the
system that we have is one of fair
office absolutely the silent caseload
has doubled since 2014 an increasing
burden on the system is I think unfair
to those already within the system
awaiting a decision we have seen uh from
numerous television pictures that the
arrivals across the channel are mainly
male
um whereas I think it would be commonly
understood that it is mainly women and
children who are the most vulnerable
um and it is also wrong I think that the
same claims should be granted after a
cross-channel migration that puts the
role of The Smuggler as a de facto part
of the Asylum process and I think it is
therefore right that we tackle this
issue robustly and I think I can put it
no better than the person who put an
enormous note through my door throughout
the weekend who said Dear Mr Randall I
implore you to vote to stop this vile
trade it has to stop and you and your
fellowing peace can make it happen well
today Mr Speaker I think we can make it
happen and we must stop this world trade
it's difficult to avoid the conclusion
that somehow or another we've landed
back in much